welcome to all of you
celebrating the european day of persons
with disabilities
let me begin with a personal memory
in my life and through my work i get to
meet
many outstanding people men and women
who with their commitment have changed
for the better
the life of many others
one of them is dr karl heinz medera
i met him years ago when i was minister
of social affairs
dr mira is a psychologist
who lived on a wheelchair since the age
of 10.
with his team he helps persons with
disability
learn a job that fulfills their
aspirations and many many other things
when i met him he told me
what persons with disabilities want is
to be part of society
just like everyone else we should all be
the masters of our own life
for persons with disabilities it can be
difficult to find a new job
they are constantly confronted with
barriers that sometimes are simply
insurmountable and this should not be so
persons with disabilities have the right
to have good conditions in the workplace
to live independently
to equal opportunities to participate
fully in the life of their community
all have a right to a life without
barriers
and it is our obligation as a community
to ensure their full participation in
society
on an equal basis with others
this is true for all people whatever the
personal story may be
almost one in four europeans is a person
with disability
millions of people young and old
many of you are here today and it is
you we have to listen to when
shaping our future commitments and
actions
this year life has been harder because
of the pandemic
for some it is very hard to follow an
online lesson
or to receive the health care they need
in the middle of a lockdown
the pandemic has highlighted
inequalities
that already existed for example in the
access to education
to health care and to essential support
services
our new recovery plan next generation eu
can help us shape a more inclusive
economy and society
when pushing forward the green and the
digital transitions
this is also a great opportunity and
chance
to remove existing barriers for example
in our buildings
or in education in healthcare
and in the jobs market or the
european green deal renovation wave for
example
can pave the way for more accessible
buildings
and we will invest in skills and
infrastructure for all europeans
all included
everyone should enjoy the same rights
equality and non-discrimination
a fundamental values set out in our
treaties
and this is the european union that i
want
the union that we are working to build
and there is progress even in these
difficult circumstances
today we celebrate european cities
that have taken to heart the rights of
their citizens
last year's award went to warsaw
the city worked closely with persons
with disability
to make it a better place to live
in warsaw for instance all metro
stations
are now fully accessible
now you will learn this afternoon who
is the winner of this year's access city
award
these are cities that strive to work for
their people
cities that all of their citizens can
call
home where everyone can have
a full life these cities are models
for all of us they are a reminder
that even the most long-standing
barriers and prejudices
can be tore down
ten years ago the european union
ratified the un convention on the rights
of persons with disabilities
it was the first human rights convention
to be ratified by the european union
and this is not just symbolic the
united nations regularly assess whether
the european union
is complying with the obligations set in
the convention
and we know there is room for
improvement
we are part of this un convention not
because we are perfect
but because we know that we still have a
long way to go
and this is why next year we will
present a new strategy on the rights of
persons with disabilities
a strategy for change our goal is a
union of equality
a union where everyone can enjoy the
same rights
and opportunities where we are
all equal with all our differences
a continent where we can finally be
united in diversity thank you